an email address is the ideal Target for
a Cyber attack according to FBI's
calculations in 2021 companies lost 2.4
billion dollars in phishing attacks
alone via email scammers can not only
try to get hold of your personal data
but also extort money from you this is
social engineering designed to Target
gullible people you might get an email
like this in your inbox a hacker writes
that he has the password to one of your
social media accounts you're already
feeling a bit concerned right he claims
that he has a juicy video that he
recorded through your webcam and if you
don't transfer him the money he'll send
it to your friends if you get an email
like this don't respond otherwise the
hacker might continue to spam you with
emails of course in no situation should
you send him money Mark the email as
spam and delete it reset the password of
all accounts that use that compromised
password as their login if you have
already paid the scammer contact the
police and tell them what happened leave
a like if you want more videos about
social engineering